Your clock's running.
Yeah, I saw it.
All right.
So we all know the current treatment approach for FLT3-mutated AML includes a FLT3 inhibitor.
The approved drugs here are in red.
And the reason that we have these drugs and they are approved is because, hey, they work.
They improve survival.
And you only need 14 days of FLT3 inhibitor during induction or consolidation, plus or
minus maintenance, which was done on these studies, to show a survival advantage with
this approach.
The problem with this is if we look at the patients who aren't getting intensive chemotherapy,
a current standard of care is not actually to give a targeted inhibitor front line because
it hasn't been shown in a randomized setting to improve survival.
I'm going to talk about some of the data that I think are leading towards studies that
hopefully will confirm a benefit for that approach.
If we look at what Veneza does for FLT3-positive patients, we know overall for VLEA, there
was a survival benefit for patients treated with a combination over-aided placebo.
But when we look at the FLT3-mutated patients, while it does look like their survival is
better.
That's almost entirely attributed to the FLT3-TKD-positive patients, as was shown on
follow-up data that Marina Karnopleva had published.
The FLT3-positive patients have overlapping survival with the non-FLT3-mutated patients.
So no clear benefit of adding VEN.
And indeed, the ELN 2024 classification for lower-intensity therapy shows FLT3 to
be a lower-benefit group.
So what can we do to improve outcome?
We can improve remission rates with adding venetoclax to azacitidine, but it doesn't
actually improve survival.
Well, we have drugs that are effective in the salvage setting.
What if we move them forward?
We've looked at gilturitinib frontline with low-intensity therapy, initially with azacitidine
alone.
That actually was halted early because it was clear there was no survival benefit.
Maybe a little better outcome in patients with high allyl burden, but the differences
are small.
There's been VEN plus gilt data in the relapsed refractory setting.
And in the interest of time, I've not included those data other than to say it's feasible.
It's tolerable.
It's very mildly suppressive.
So with that setting the stage, venetoclax azacitidine and gilturitinib was developed as a
triplet, initially at MD Anderson, single-institution study, initially in the relapsed refractory
setting, showing very similarly high remission rates to ven gilt in that population, but
really remarkable response rates in the frontline setting in newly diagnosed patients, where
the complete remission rates here were 90%, another 6% for CRI, and these remission rates
actually exceed what we've seen.
What we see for intensive chemotherapy at any age.
So this is really impressive data.
And while it's a small number of patients that have been treated, only about 20 of these are
FLT3 FLT3 positive, and there are FLT3 TKDs here.
I think everybody kind of was taken aback by just how good the data looked for this.
And the question would be, you know, how long would this hold up?
Would it improve survival?
Are you getting deep remissions?
And the answer to all of these is it looks a lot better than we're seeing with other regimens.
The survivals do look better in non-randomized data.
These are all single arm studies.
They do achieve deep remissions in terms of FLT3 FLT3 burden reduction by ultra-sensitive FLT3 FLT3,
NGS, MRD, the majority of patients actually clear detectable FLT3 FLT3 by in vivo scribe.
And the downside to it is just the degree of myelosuppression, again,
that when you add Ven and Gil together, it takes a very long time to recover your counts.
Now, they were not seeing early mortality, but we always wonder, is that the Houston water?
There's something about treating patients in Houston, and they just do better.
So what we really want to know is, can we do this everywhere?
Not just here.
And so, oh, and I should also say this was not due to transplant.
When they looked at the patients that went on to transplant, there was not an obvious survival benefit for the transplanted patients.
It really just looks like the regimen.
And some of this has to do with treating older patients.
The median age on this study, I think, is 74 years and a high non-relapse mortality, obviously, in this older group.
So can we do this everywhere is the question.
And this was the reason for putting the Viceroy study together, which was a pharma-sponsored study that was multi-adjusted.
And it was a study that was a little bit more traditional, but also both community oncology groups and also academic centers.
So it was really trying to get a sense of can you do this anywhere.
And while we looked at two different doses of venetoclax, 200 milligrams and 400 milligrams, in the end, actually, there wasn't a big difference in terms of response rates to either of the doses.
They were both similarly high.
Again, nearly everybody went into a protocol-defined CR, CRI, or CRH.
And the survivals here look pretty much overlapping with what was experienced from MDN.
So it's not actually the water in Houston.
And this can be done outside of the bubble.
And we did look at MRD clearance and similarly high, although the numbers here are very, very small.
So it kind of sets the stage for what we're doing with myelomatch, which is we have very exciting single-arm data.
What can we do in a randomized setting?
Can we actually move the needle by showing, you know, once and for all, that really adds value to add a third drug here?
And so the myelomatch study, as I've described before, it's very, very important.
And it's nice to be described by Dr. Weiner here, randomizes patients who are not considered ideal candidates for intensive chemotherapy, either by age or comorbidity, generally people over the age of 60, to either vaneza as a standard arm, given just as it was done on the VLEA study, or one of two triplet regimens, one where the regimen is pretty much exactly as given on Nick Short's study from Anderson.
And the other is where we tried to do it kind of as it's done in the setting of intensive chemotherapy.
Where you give 14 days of giltaritinib after vaneza, which is given for seven days.
And we wanted to actually start the gilt then, but AbbVie got very upset and said, we need the synergy of giving it together.
So we said, fine.
So there is actually seven days of overlap of the venetoclax and the azacitidine on each of the cycles.
We shall see how this all turns out.
But I think ultimately the question is, if it turns out as good as what we have seen, we now have two really good options from frontline for somebody eligible for any.
You could get intensive chemotherapy plus a TKI and go on to intensive chemotherapy and a TKI if you're not going to go on to transplant or go on to a transplant.
You could get venetoclax, azacitidine, and giltaritinib and get whatever is appropriate based on, again, MRD clearance, perhaps.
Or maybe we need to be doing a study that's doing this, which is to randomize and say, really, if we have two good options and one is probably a heck of a lot easier, similar to what we've shown in Paradigm, do we really need intensive chemotherapy to achieve long-term fantastic therapy?
We're seeing fantastic outcomes compared to what we used to see for FLT3 mutated patients.
These look really much better.
And I really must say we're seeing fewer and fewer relapses of FLT3 mutated patients no matter what we're doing frontline.
And it's really heartening to see 80-year-old patients who are two and three years out from initial diagnosis still in remission with these kinds of approaches.
And we are seeing that regularly.
We never saw this before.
So it's really exciting to see this.
And just in conclusion, we are going to clearly improve remission rates with this approach.
The big question is, is there value to it?
Myelomatch is not designed to give definitive treatment effects.
It's a signal-finding design.
But I hope that we will at least provide a strong signal that says that there's something real about this.
I do think vanadizagil could be an attractive approach for younger, fitter patients.
And randomized studies of those kinds of approaches are actually in the works for this year.
And then lastly, for the NPM1 mutated patients, and Gus and I were having this conversation this morning, what's the right third drug?
Should it be a menin inhibitor?
Should it be a FLT3?
Should it be a FLT3 inhibitor?
Should it be both drugs?
I don't think anybody really knows.
And maybe quadruplets will be, like in myeloma, the new thing we shall see.
Thanks for your attention.